[Applause]
you won the fight now you're gonna break
your neck
[Applause]
that sounds like somebody's mama binium
takes home the trophy from his first
official mma fight and he breaks down in
tears in awe that his dream came true
plus things get a little hot and
romantic between him and ari
are you so sexy baby
[Music]
it's my little guy
my cheek
this was a fun episode for these two
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
i hope wherever you are in the world you
are feeling good and if you're not i
hope our time together makes you feel
better oh
come give me a big hug a few updates
before we talk binyam kicking
literally
i spoke to eve and asked a number of
your big questions
how can you be in a committed
relationship and not have these serious
conversations about your cultural
differences we were kind of focused on
the love maybe not necessarily the real
inter-workings of precise
religious topics how do you feel about
muhammad picking and choosing what to
follow and what not to follow about his
religion
so when something seems like it's a
double standard or has an aspect of like
hypocrisy in it no that doesn't sit well
with me we had a good chat she's a
beautiful woman and one-on-one she does
have a very calming energy
but
we had to get real
by the way i appreciate your questions
to hear my conversation with eve make
sure you subscribe to entertainment
tonight's youtube channel so you don't
miss the interview
you can also check it out on et
online.com i had to buy a ring oh you
did not i did
in other interesting news this week
emily buys herself an engagement ring
without telling kobe and where they do
that because she didn't want to walk
around with the cheap one kobe bought on
the street in china i like have to wear
a ring forever so i wanted to be
something that i love it's not that i
don't have faith in kobe but i also
don't want to put that much pressure on
him
so my
eyes
okay if you can't afford it and can't
get one then i'll buy myself one i'm
really not understanding emily's logic
here if kobe can't afford it how can she
just last week she asked her parents to
help pay for the wedding
so what if he finds one and he buys it
and you don't like it as much as this
ring
i think i'm just gonna have to suck it
up and take the ring he gives me yeah
okay
well on next week's episode it looks
like kobe is going to buy her a ring and
to be real all i can think is
priorities come on guys
but if it's that important to emily so
be it kobe knows
happy life happy life speaking of that
let's go ahead and get into ari and
binium
last time we saw these two ahri went off
on mma fighter melissa in the gym after
she saw her rolling on the floor with
benny hey you didn't what's your name no
one's though what you just talked to me
no i'm talking to her what's your name
so you have full makeup i'm usually when
you get out of my way and this episode
starts with binion reacting to ari's
explosion
i'm very pissed out
she made me embarrass
oh we were embarrassed for you i don't
want what's happening again binium
confronts ari about her behavior you
know last night's like uh
very make me like i'm comfortable liking
the genitals
yeah that's yeah
yeah michelle was very uncomfortable and
she admits looking back she would have
handled things differently
i just reacted you know i didn't think
about it uh in the moment but it's just
something no one ever wants to see yeah
i would not want to see my man doing
this i'm not going to lie i would have
felt some way too ari tells binyum he
was wrong for not telling her about his
female training partner even a fighter
you i i know you'll be just you mad at
like you know you're mad about yeah he's
right
you can't not tell me things because you
think i'm gonna be mad and so is she
i feel like so many couples deal with
this someone holds back information for
the sake of keeping peace but it
destroys the trust
and in my mind i'm thinking if you're
not doing anything wrong
why can't you tell me i also understand
that some people's reactions can be a
bit extreme and it's exhausting to be
with someone you can't just say anything
to so you avoid it but i think if you
really want a relationship to work be
upfront there might be some hard
conversations you have to have and some
emotions you have to deal with but
at least over time trust will build it's
a good investment
long term you just have to tell the
truth all the time
i'm telling you just like what i have to
tell you like it was like you have to be
honest
i'm honestly
like so if you're asking me any
questions i will answer for you that's
what happens you have to work on your
honesty binium is like you didn't ask me
so i didn't tell that doesn't make me a
liar
which is true sneaky but true he goes on
to let ari know that he doesn't want to
argue because he wants to focus on his
upcoming fight and of course ari is like
you need to focus on me
can you focus on
me
listen i understand
what's uh everything like uh what are
you feeling but you have to understand
me
you know i want this game like you know
i i practice in and then i dream it for
all my life just like for like for
fighting
okay
yeah i mean i understand i want to
support your dream
and just like that bennion finds his way
out of it again
come on baby sit in my lap let me talk
sweet into your ear
he should have been doing that from the
beginning
tonight is the fight tonight
the day benjamin has been waiting for is
here
are you so sexy baby
ooh talk that talk binyum you better
tell her andy yes ari is looking good
but she's so nervous thankfully her mom
janice will be there for support and if
you're wondering if ari's dad will join
no i wasn't he's actually boycotting the
fight because he's a doctor and he
thinks these matches are extremely
dangerous so
he wants no part in it my dad is a
doctor
and
honestly
some of the statistics and the data that
he mentions are pretty scary when he
could get seriously hurt or die
so my dad's staying home watching avi
i just want to tell you you know if you
don't want to do it you don't have to
i know ari he's not 10.
and this is his dream there's no way
he's backing out when i arrive in an
event i'm so i'm so happy like when i
walk i see my dream
when it's time for binyam to get in the
ring ari and her mom are cheering and
freaking out at the same time ari's mom
who's a nurse even checked out the med
station i checked out the medics i
checked out the ambulance
i want to make sure they have everything
you gotta love janice
[Applause]
yes ari you be an mma wife
oh my god
the fight starts then booyah
bingham flies across the air with this
impressive kick
he was ready
but i'm not gonna lie as the fight went
on there were a few moments where i was
a bit nervous for benyam
[Applause]
but then he leaves the kicks behind and
goes into beast mode
[Applause]
is that ari in the background
[Applause]
she is struggling and so is benny's
opponent
there you have it ari is a nervous wreck
but binyam chokes the guy out and wins
well he didn't choke the guy out because
he didn't pass out but damn near
yeah
binium is like yes i've been waiting my
whole life for this feeling
what you did is amazing like the way you
want to fight honestly i didn't
i didn't even expect that and it was so
fast
but if i'm being honest with you the
only thing i could think about the whole
time was that poor guy that you choked
him i'm similar to ari i don't like
watching fights
some people can watch another person get
knocked out and be like oh snap
me
i'm like oh my god is he okay
i might even start crying
i'm serious
have you seen mma unboxing highlights
they can be intense
intense intense i just
i don't get it i don't get why people
sign up to suffer
but on a positive note let's clap for
binyam
this is a legit dream come true for him
that's dope when something someone has
imagined for so long
becomes their reality plus he's able to
rep his country and have a hot woman on
his shoulder binham is on top of the
world right now
[Music]
and his coach is so impressed
because he's awesome that was great 33
seconds he went in there he i saw him do
maneuvers that we practiced so that as a
coach you got to understand how amazing
that is to see and it's to see it end
that was a dominant performance and then
the back flip at the end
whoo that was the icing on the cape that
made it really nice i liked it binyam is
a star and although ahri still has
concerns that he'll continue to
prioritize this mma dream over their
relationship
which he probably will the two ended the
night on a romantic note which included
binium shedding some tears
it's my dream my dream goal
like now
with my fiance i guess this opportunity
i'm proud of you too you know it shows
you like when you really focus on
something you do a good job
i don't know i don't have words like
no i'm
birthday
wow
i was something
[Music]
it's my little guy
huh
look at that wok binyam is a happy man
right now congrats benny alright next
week ari's ex-husband leandro is back
yep you heard me right
i'm gonna see leandra is one of my best
friends who's also my ex-husband hey
wow
i don't trust leandro she's too close to
ari her family is my family so
we are family now
binium saw how cute arie was looking and
said no i'm coming alright 90 day fans
fam make sure you stick with et because
we are covering it all i will see you
next time
[Music]